as you may know that cosmic rays when
they bombard the atmosphere generate a
small amount of the radioactive form of
carbon called carbon-14 so plants and
other biological organisms incorporate
small amounts of this radioactive
carbon-14 when people sell alcoholic
drinks there's always the slight worry
whether the alcohol the ethanol in it is
industrial ethanol that has been made
from petroleum from crude oil or it is
really from plants and the simplest way
to test is that ethanol that has been
made from plant material is slightly
radioactive in fact I've been told I
don't know whether this is true that
it's illegal to sell alcoholic drinks in
America unless they're radioactive and
contain carbon-14
because carbon-14 decays with a
half-life of about 5000 years so that
means after 5000 years half the carbon
14 has decayed and since oil has been
under the ground for millions of years
all the carbon-14 has long since gone